so we begin with breaking news from
india where defense chief general bipin
rawat and 12 other officials have been
killed in a helicopter crash
the helicopter came down in the near
district of southern tamil nadu states
one person survived it's not known why
it crashed an investigation
is now underway let's cross over to new
delhi our correspondent elizabeth
pronoun uh joins us from there now liz
what more do we know
hello nick so the indian air force
tweeted a short while ago saying that it
is with deep regret that they have
ascertained that general bipin rawat mrs
madhulika rawat that is bipin rawat's
wife and 11 others
were killed in the
in the helicopter crash there were 14
people on board 13 have died and one is
being treated in hospital and the
government administrator in the district
of nilgiris where the crash took place
he has said that the
identity of the bodies has to be
confirmed using dna testing because of
the severe burns now
63 year old general bipin rawath is the
chief of defence staff it is a newly
created position in january of last year
and he's the first person to hold it he
was the former army chief of staff and
the chief of defense staff is actually
it was created to integrate the army the
navy and the air force and it is the
highest ranking position in the indian
armed forces now he was traveling on a
helicopter on a helicopter that was
going from an air force in sulur to the
defense service college in wellington
in wellington for an event it was not
supposed to be a very long ride but this
is a very mountainous region
with a lot of forests and as you
mentioned the indian air force has
ordered an inquiry to ascertain what
exactly caused the crash prime minister
narendra modi is holding a meeting now
with the um with the defense chiefs in
the country and the defense minister was
actually supposed to address parliament
late on wednesday afternoon about the
incident but he will be doing that on
thursday morning
because he went to the rawat residence
in new delhi
instead of addressing parliament
all right let's leave it there for the
moment thanks very much indeed elizabeth
from new delhi